à traduire servais saint
georges ça y
est vous rendez vous n'avez pas intérêt
à remuer se doit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un tas de gens qui disent un tas de
choses mais il faut surtout s'écouter
soi même
ce moment là elvis l'homme su sacrifier
et elvis le dieu était né
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'avait aucune idée de ce qu'il avait
fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je souhaite vous représentez monsieur
presley
demain toute l'amérique parlera de mon
gars
c'est qui celui là alors que elvis
presley
mais c'est pas toi qui est aux manettes
ils vont tous deux bouffées
faire ce que j'ai envie de faire chanter
la musique que je veux
tu es
oui c'est ce ma
maman et vont mettre en prison un façon
de chanter c'est un ton tu sais alors il
va pas y avoir du mal à ça
si vous ne m'écoutez pas tout vous faut
changer
tous les sacrifices que votre maman a
fait auront été bien
croyez moi
beaucoup parlé d'une nouvelle puce
[Applaudissements]
ces gens là pourront pas me changer
je pense que si c'est ton frère tu y
arriveras
jamais rencontré quelqu'un comme toi
j'espère bien
[Musique]
tél
sans moi il n'y aurait pas de elvis
prestley
la pasteur m'a dit un jour
quand les choses sont trop dangereuses à
dire
jordi
les jeux
c'est par un concert nostalgique on va
faire un truc différent